watch the offensive rebounding here  in for davis  [Music]  went up high and came down hard and the  lakers have it they come the other way  clippers down by one  jackson  spin up and down  what a great court screw move  clippers by one  no timeout  here's davis  the other way into traffic but if it  goes it's over  and the clippers have survived  in a thriller  wow what  a game  and russell westbrook they've been  running this all night long  reggie jackson and the clippers  they got the switch they wanted with  reeds  and reggie jackson  this shot by anthony davis just in and  out at the buzzer you couldn't have  asked for a better look here  by a.d  but what about  jackson of the clippers who had 10 in  the fourth quarter  and six of the last nine  la clipper points he was